i don't know anybody who's who's [ __ ]
with you when it comes to net worth
buddy at this point well if you look at
like cookies clothing cookies cannabis
if you look at buyer's papers vibes is
on a crazy
crazy run crazy traction like i i get
anxious thinking about that you think
about like equity and weed maps and you
look at stuff like g pen and santa cruz
shredder and you know things that people
forgot i have my hands in like there's a
crazy ecosystem of very valuable
companies and
it's kind of spooky sometimes man i just
you know i heard listen let me i heard a
rumor that that cookies was offered
uh
pretty much to get bought for like close
to a billion dollars and you guys turned
that down is that true yeah now we get
crazy offers all the time someone was
just sitting down with us recently
trying to get us to go
take our [ __ ] out in the canadian
canadian stock market and whatnot and
the numbers they were talking about
there if we went out like it's crazy and
i just like the way i look at is like
that [ __ ] ain't real i just keep my head
down keep trying to focus on you know
how do we keep this [ __ ] running i don't
even think because if you focus on the
numbers too much you'll get caught up in
that you'll get comfortable i'm never
comfortable you know we had we had this
[ __ ] set up at noon i was i'd text you
hell early could we do earlier yeah i
mean of course because i always work
right and i think i got that from my
pops you know i mean like i just never
really focus on it but to get to your
point yeah the net worth is probably
pretty pretty powerful right now and i
don't even know when or how that's going
to happen knocking on a billion
yeah probably i think so i think so i
mean i don't really know i mean i know
cookies is
i know next time we raise money for
cookies it's going to be in the multiple
billions so
just look at that like that well i mean
it seems as if to like
any time there's a new market that
becomes legal
there's like three cookie stores that
open in the state straight up and then
you've got lemonade too
yeah and lemonade is another brand that
your sister brand yes sister you don't
want to over water every you know hella
cookie stores you know cookies like nike
town almost right but
we came with the sister brand lemonade
which is killing it too